[Music]
did you guys
know that there is a micro nation
in italy that has a princess and it's
not the vatican
a small nation or there's a nation oh
yeah the vatican is technically a micro
nation
yeah so this is a this is a small town
named saborga and it's high up in the
hills above the italian riviera
wow saborga there's a little country
right on top of italy called luxembourg
yeah luxembourg
you can rent it out you can rent out the
whole country yeah you could rent out
the whole country
what why would you do that like for what
you saw it on zillow or something
no check it out looks we got internet
now yeah we didn't rent
luxembourg what do you mean you got
internet now we didn't have it before
we had some shitty ass internet we could
never look anything up yeah i know i
know what that internet is
but for a cool 70 000
a night for a minimum of two nights you
can hire the tiny country
of wait that's a different one
lichtenstein oh lechenstein that's a
small country
oh electrifying which measures at around
61.7 square miles and has just 35 000.
oh let's just stein's a smaller country
yeah that one i was thinking luxembourg
luxembourg's not that small compared to
legend
luxembourg is known for being the
richest country right per
capita or something like per person that
lives there it's actually unrentable
what do you do with the country when you
rent it seventy thousand dollars a day
maybe like seventy thousand yeah a day
with a minimum of
or a night that sounds pretty cheap to
rent a whole country yeah what are 50
000.
so it's not just really like what are
you can you establish a new government
during that time
can you well a rapper rented it and then
they didn't let him or some [ __ ] because
he wanted to do a music video or
something
so it's just a gigantic movie music
video set
yeah so it's just like a space that you
can rent says that you could
you can customize street signs temporary
currency
and accommodation for a hundred and
fifty people i could do jomalia for a
day
thousand damn every time it's like a
hundred and forty thousand because it's
a minimum of two nights split that
between 150 people
10 grand yeah would say what play it has
500
signs your street name dude next company
trip
let's do it we're renting out that
[ __ ] license snipes
lichenstein you know what i would do
i would do a a national parade that
would be
so sick that would be cuz you know like
when you watch those north korean
parades don't that motivate you like
oh man look at them rockets oh they got
[ __ ] rockets dude oh look at how they
march
how do they get the they're so in sync
is the military oh they're so cool
yeah but like the size of this country
you're gonna have like a 15 minute
parade
it could have so it says it could
accommodate between 450 and 900 people
and has 500 plus
bedrooms and 500 plus bathrooms 500
bedrooms for the entire country
for 900 people so they're assuming a lot
of couples are in there
the cancellation policy is classified as
super strict which means you
get a 50 refund after booking if you
cancel up to 30 days yeah and cancel
culture dude
70 a thousand to rent a country a 70 000
a lot of money
but it's not a lot if you think about a
country there's like some houses on
zillow oh yeah with snoop dogg that was
trying to do
a video oh there's some houses on zillow
like 70 000 a day they didn't let snoop
dogg
well it says airbnb's new offer follows
last year's attempt by
my snoop dogg to rent lichenstein to
shoot a music video he was rebuffed
because his management did not give
enough prior warning sorry oh kind of
organization they didn't want they don't
want a twerking parade maybe
yeah maybe so a nuclear silo parade is
much better
yeah so what about this aborga okay so
support
now uh its princess is declaring
independence because of an according to
them an invite i thought they were
already independent
invalid pact i don't know it's called a
small principality
so it's probably not antana state maybe
it's kind of like a
it's kind of like a vice i don't know
it's like state like i don't know what
do you know it's province the hong kong
kind of thing but not as big and
i don't know i see with no economy you
know what she's really saying is she's
like koopa got me mario come save me
[Laughter]
you have to get her at the hill because
she lives on she's a princess on the
hill right
yeah 320
residents 320 residents so according to
the legend
the kings of templar hid the holy grail
in this village
oh [ __ ] i bet you they didn't though
that's what that's why they said legend
like there's no actual
they're saying that there's no actual
proof that there were any templar
knights templar there um but okay so
they're saying ever since 1963 saborga
has claimed that it is an
independent nation national entity a
micro nation
uh and it's called the principality of
saborga
and so this pact was they were saying
back in the day so in 954 the village
became property
of an order of these monks and then
according to suborgans
the abbott of the monks was then given
the royal title
of prince by the holy roman empire in
1079.
then in 1697 the town was bought by the
savoy dynasty and and then they're
saying that
so the suborgans insist that that
transaction was never
legally registered so then that didn't
really count
and so that's why technically they are
independent
and so right now and they're bringing up
this topic 400 years later
no so this has been like a thing that
there's been like this
like power struggle kind of kind of like
catalonia in spain
yeah yeah exactly kind of like that and
so
as of right now like the current
princess so she just got
voted in because her ex-husband
was the prince he he was doing like the
seventh
uh wait sorry one thing so she's not
royalty by lineage she got married in
yeah and she's asking for independence
okay so her ex-husband yeah so well
catherine catherine the great
was that the she's an empress of russia
[ __ ] bad ass girl dude
she she's like uh she married into
royalty though
yeah yeah she's a she's a killer so her
ex-husband
abdicated last year in the middle of his
second seven years why did he abdicate
the phone
thrown i don't know i don't want the
phone anymore
abdicate the phone this is not iphone
i don't want it yeah so he was in his
second seven-year term as
princess borga and so the people really
loved princess nina
and so nina's better they backed her up
but there was this other chick that was
trying to
get the crown and uh nina ended up
beating her in the elections
so that's why she became princess and
she was supposed to get crowned
in may but then because of coronavirus
for royalty i know you could be elected
royalty according to this
this place yeah and if you win they just
pump you with the blood a little bit
just so you have it in your real blood
yeah it's all a wild story uh and then
there's
there's also this dude from france that
he claims that he's like
like his ancestor somehow is like
he's he's entitled to get the country
and be prince
because of his game of thrones yeah it
literally is like a game of thrones
situation right now happening in italy
and so he's trying to like get in and
saying like
i've already done so much for saborga go
to brazil
and they know about us because of the
work i've done
and then like the the people reporting
this they hit up brazil and they're like
[ __ ]
we don't know who the [ __ ] this is
what's the borga why brazil is so
specific i guess because he's trying to
prove like see i'm giving international
attention to
the saborga like our country our micro
nation
this freaking youtube channel is about
to give way more attention to sport
right now yeah the views on this video
is like way more than 350 000 people
yeah
yeah so right now they're saying like
there's there's like
a whole bunch of powers man this
[ __ ] bakersfield got more people
than this
[ __ ] country dude damn thank you
you know what i mean i want to be the
prince of bakersfield
what's the big deal right it's like
you've got to let brazil know about
bakersfield
the [ __ ] mayor of redwood california
has more
people under that town so there's a
local suborgan
named gustav he has written the book
on the town's history and he claims
that this dude that's saying that he has
a right to be prince that
he does have a right to declare that he
wants to be prince because technically
the formal title doesn't exist and no
one can stop you from saying you're the
prince or princess
and every now and then people come
forward to do so this
i'm confused to me it just sounds like
the okay so this is no different than
like people fighting over the mayor role
in a small ass town
but if you think about it it's 300
population
that shit's that's a village dude you
know everybody but they call it a
village yeah
that shit's [ __ ] smaller than el paso
texas it's smaller than a high school
that's true the student body's way
bigger than that they need to get their
[ __ ] artifacts in order like get all
the [ __ ] old scrolls and [ __ ] and
read to highlight that [ __ ]
read about damn highlight yes
highlighter old scroll
this document is from 900. on that show
what are the key words in this
yellow or blue or pink today because i'm
imagining like a castle and all this
[ __ ]
but really they have a population of a
[ __ ] road stop where you get gasoline
yeah you know what i mean like bar stock
it's smaller than barstow like what do
they got there like an outlet just
outlets right yeah
no but going back to what you're saying
it's like they have been reviewing the
the
old artifacts yeah documents and they're
saying that historians
have never discovered the original deed
and so because of that
it makes the sale invalid and
they're like you know we're independent
then bro they lost the pink slip to the
country
to the country so they're saying because
of the reason that that
there is no deed that saborga would not
have been included in the unification of
italy in 1861
or the formation of the republic in 1941
in italy's like
shut up oh you're only 300 people
yeah so here's a gas station stop
princess nina who actually splits her
time between
saborga and monaco because she has a
business that floor looks tight though
it does is that like a compass that's
the templar symbol huh
it's probably got some like actual holy
grail kind of history there yeah they
did say
this kind of reminds me of like croatia
it looks cool
why would they even want to be
independence like all right cool we did
it that's the whole residence hall
everybody lives in there what's their
economy there it's like if they're
independent like they have to be
self-sustainable then
the gas station so the reason why
princess nina won the election is
because she has like
high uh she's like really motivated she
has a lot of great invite
great ideas to get more tourists to come
into the town to stimulate
the economy and so they're saying like
she wants to have seborga
be on the cruise ship uh brochures and
have like a cable car
from the sea to the town i'm quite sure
if that's gonna work anymore
well that's very like the mirror analogy
to like a talent like i am the princess
i need to save this country we need a
cable car
we need to make sure that carnival
cruises stops by twice a year we're
gonna bring a chick-fil-a down over here
on atlantic
yeah people come way more creating the
corporations right
that's the reason why she wants to be
uh independent and also make her own
decisions
yeah well it's like it's maybe we need a
starbucks stimulate the economy within
this
this place because they're really just
being left behind they need two gas
stations and then also with this whole
like
pandemic and stuff like it's just really
crazy so her coronation
is rescheduled for august 20th and so
she's hoping that that
ceremony will draw in fans and
hopefully it will oh they're also
planning to reintroduce the local
currency
and build a luxury hotel and just
try to really get tourism in there i
want to go
yeah if you visit there make sure you
use the discount code jknews
for ten percent off everything maps
or princess nina it's so funny
tourism it's a town mayor she has to
have a second job
right and monaco like in a different
town princess
i bet she's going to hit you guys up for
a collab watch i know hey we'll promote
it
we worked with croatia you know true
always the whole country
like on the government no it was yeah
well the tournament comes
we had the traveling wait you guys went
to croatia what
oh that's where you got the truffles
yeah the truffle one i want to go to
croatia i heard their beaches are
spectacular
and i heard that yeah the whole region
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can run around yeah you can get
a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you